this has been Tiger COO Ollie's home for
more than three days now a small tent is
all he and his family have there are no
showers no running water and not enough
food the 42 year old chemist who studied
in Germany managed to escape his home in
war-torn Syria but now at the a Damini
camp he's facing a new set of
circumstances human rights organizations
describe conditions here as a
humanitarian crisis we live like animals
here does this guy live as he's angry
now so V this is not a good life you can
see how the children live how their toys
look this is no life I'm father this is
kinda amid poor conditions refugees try
to go about their everyday lives a visit
to the barber helps restore a bit of
dignity at a price of 3 euros there is
no electricity here in the camp but
people have improvised a solution
connecting outlets to a generator to
keep their mobile phones running with a
thousand new arrivals each day the camp
is nearing its limits
garbage collectors are unable to cope
this is a domain ease major problem
refugees are living in fields of garbage
people hang their clothes to dry on
portable toilets trash is everywhere and
eight organizations fear disease could
quickly spread within the camp NGOs like
doctors of the world treats several
hundred patients each day most are under
five years old this Iraqi family has
brought their babies suffering from flu
symptoms and a high fever hygienic
conditions get worse worse and now we
have many cases of escapees but we what
we really are worried about is the
possibility of heavies I mean kind of of
outbreak epidemic outbreak for example
measles for example polio meningitis
cholera measles is our major concern
right now it's because of these health
concerns that Tizer Kiraly and his
family rarely leave their tent their
biggest wish is to have a hot shower and
to leave it emini as soon as possible
there's no indication this will happen
anytime soon